Der Winter war zurück am Wochenende.
In weiten Teilen Deutschlands mit Schnee und
eisigem Wind.
In Winterberg im Sauerland nutzten viele am
Samstag noch mal den Schnee für Ski und Rodelspaß
- oder einfach für einen Winterspaziergang.
Am Flughafen Frankfurt bedeutete das kalte
Wetter dann eher Mehrarbeit: Die Enteiser
hatten gut zu tun, um die Flugzeuge startklar
zu machen.
Dennoch mussten nach Angaben des Flughafenbetreibers
Fraport 150 Flüge ausfallen.
In Winterberg richteten sich am Samstag schon
erste Hoffnungen auf den Frühling: "Das ist
das letzte Aufbäumen, bevor es jetzt richtig
Frühling wird, und das ist klasse, und da
freuen wir uns drauf."
Da dürfte aber noch etwas Geduld nötig sein.
Die Meteorologen sagen für die nächsten
Tage weiter Minusgrade voraus.